hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play Minotaur maze
now you guys got a hold on for a sec
just listen to this music and it's
freaking uh-huh stuff that's what it is
right now okay wait so there's a
Minotaur maze and the gist of it I stole
this from me on that's by the way but
the gist of it is that you play in a
maze and you're trying to get out that's
it okay oh I can customize my own level
sighs this goes ten by ten for now oh
hello
okay so I can hide the cursor with H I
read in the controls and now I'm
wandering through this series of dark
halls to do anything well I was hardly
fair
what ah
yo okay alright okay hold on a second
this have been too much kind of kindly
to hold your tits mister Minotaur okay
so basically I guess I need to run what
okay hold on a second here I'm gonna go
back to the main menu if we're gonna
hold on a second here while we evaluate
the scenario okay obviously it's too
dang small so let's go maximum size and
was it 17 by 17 okay now everything
needs to just calm the hell down cuz I'm
trying to escape a frickin maze okay
escape a de maiz perfect I'll do just
that
while not trying to encounter a Minotaur
okay I hear it where is it I would like
to see it you know before I die
off my head off does unnatural things
with my dead corpse hello
okay I hear it I hear it now where's the
exit
that's what I want to know right now I'm
finally a little bit away from him so
now I need to go find the exit wherever
that may be okay 1717 by 17 may have
been pretty damn big what the hell
Oh where's the ajik don't kill me bro
I'm too pretty to die don't kill me
don't kill me don't kill me oh oh man
that thing where was it it wasn't even
near me I didn't think so
I don't know I don't know where I'm
going
oh no where I'm wrong who the hell was
going on here hello hello is it behind
me I bet it's behind me isn't it
yes I've got him cellphone 17 by 17 was
not a good idea okay you know what you
know what broham
hi that's going you stuck uh-huh you're
stuck ain't you oh oh you know yeah okay
we're going back to the lobby here cuz I
was just ridiculous this game is a
little bit too much for me it's too fast
bass let's try the smallest level sighs
now okay okay start the game escape the
maze couldn't be simpler couldn't be
simpler
oh come on
how did you spot me you were miles away
maybe oh maybe he hurt me okay the music
needs to not be that it's a little too
intense oh come on what are you saying
like he's perma spotting me now
it's not big Oh bull I'm going back to
the lobby this game
okay just calmly okay I hear you you're
over there no now
oh oh I don't know I don't know I don't
like this Gabe I like it not good
I got no chance up god dammit stop her
head I just want to live oh whoa I want
to live don't kill me
let me find the exit please please sir
may I have the exit ah
dead end can I get out still I thought
it was gonna give me for sure okay still
alive this maze is still very mem all
right all right all right all right you
know what I'm gonna give this one last
try
I'm gonna give it one good last try and
it's gonna get me the exit
give me the exit go learn and I Minotaur
admit it took table damn it I did it
again maybe it's the same layout baby's
right there
okay so I'm still in the same layout
that's what's going on no no
no it is different it's different I've
spawned in a different place Wow ah
count it wait I'm still running hey I
escaped escape
I did it what's going on now what yay i
won
I guess I'm so confused but anyway this
game has a multiplayer setting so if you
want to see me play this with other
people let me know in the comments below
I'm so confused anyway so hope you
enjoyed it I guess so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
this is kind of the
there's no other game that's like
that's how you just walked myself
morning